- I remember seeing Vince
as a young kid.
And I tell this story during every interview, but
I was in the stands as a young kid,
he’s my favorite player,
wearing the full purple and gold,
the shoes and everything,
full everything.
- You were Vinced out
- Vinced out! Headband.
I didn’t even need- I didn't like wearing headbands
but I wore it just cuz of Vince,
and I yelled his name as-
as um, as hard as I could.
And I was like,
“Vince Carter! Vince Carter!”
and I could tell, like,
he's in the game,
like he's in the game and
he's got this kid out of nowhere just heckling at him.
And I'm just sitting there so excited, I’m asking,
“Can I yell his name?”
And he looked up and he went like this
and I'll never forget about that.
I remember the story.
I remember the day,
- Just the gesture.
- just going like, just going like that.
So when I see a kid
or I see a fan,
even adults.
It’s kind of weird with adults, cuz
it’s like, you should understand, like, just give me-
- Yeah.
- You know, just take a-
Just chill. But-
- Yeah, chill out. We’re grown.
- But when I see a kid, at least, um
with that kind of excitement, like, I don’t-
I just drop everything.
You know, I don't have to
carry that with me when I see a kid
so happy.
Cuz that moment changed my life.
That moment changed my outlook, my
perception on people,
all that stuff.
So just by when I was six years old,
I remember that, that changed me.